oui qu'est-ce qui se passe moi j'ai un
compte un coup de gueule contre
l'émission mariée au premier regard ah
oui alors vous avez compris le concept
pour nos invités
ils se connaissent pas ils sont
compatibles et ses oiseaux et les
otaries direct j'ai fais absolument
scandaleuse c'est à dire que moi je
crois à l'amour j'aime l'amour
j'aime le mariage ouais c'est que c'est
l'amour qui vous aiment pas mais je
continue de croire et moi de voir deux
personnes et notamment hier la femme
d'hier soir qui croyaient la de cette
jeune trentenaire et qui se fait bâcher
juste avant légumes franchement c'est
terrible on est à deux jours de la
saint-valentin
il ya plein d'hommes qui sont désespérés
comme moi et la voir une image des gens
qui accroît la fête des gouttes et
franchement ça fait de la peine
et ça me saoule comme s'ils se rendent
dans ce jeu là ah oui honte à vous de
mettre cette émission alors huawei
j'adore cette émission vous avouez quand
même que ça me ferait alors si en hausse
par rapport au lancement de la saison
dernière avec francesca ce qui m'énerve
c'est unis toujours à la place des
autres
ils ont pas mal ils sont volontaires ça
les amuse de faire l'émission ils sont
volontaires pour faire cette expérience
ils ont réactivé son âge il est très
gênant et et pour te mets des deux ris
et oui on devrait vivre le feu mais pas
maintenant luxe yachts et violent déjà
alors et non le bien sera une expérience
des aides arrivent mars à mai mois cyril
c'est une expérience sénat va geler
l'eau périence est ma télé c'est une
aventure aussi énormes ne s'est pas
laissée par les bd humains à qui aucun
couple qui a réussi c'est wayne rooney
bref plus juste la de base de dire que
de façon scientifique
il ya deux âmes qui sont faites pour
être heures pardonnez-moi mais l'amour
c'est tout sauf s'il est tombé mais la
us que vous parlez anglais ici vous
répète un couple qui peut être tout de
suite compatible mois par me gilles et
daniel j'y crois
pourquoi pas avec toi moi alémanique
vachement l'arrière retrouver des
risques de 13 ans
à jos et je pense à votre crise ce
serait complète avec qui parce que j'ai
pris beaucoup de recul là depuis qu'elle
va prôner un peu plus et je pense que
franchement il y aurait un petit un truc
à la bernard monté avec bernard montiel
bernard on se connaît depuis très
longtemps je n'ai rien fait j'ai rien
dit je sais rien obama ont semblé n'est
plus très longtemps
oui je sais pas mais ça fait c'est comme
une évidence des mois tous les salaires
[Musique]
je connais bien bernard oui et je me dis
que tu n'as pas tout à fait tort
maintenant on est à 60 à nielles les
deux mais il est même les logis
séparément vous êtes book mais ensemble
vous seriez way a de la gueule du gamin
alors comme vous avez gbb ils vont
tester tabitha gueule chérie de 210 dur
de garder sa place là parce que ma soeur
et moi plus christine alors je dis
quelque chose d'intelligent et bâtir et
cela pas bon alors il va déjà déjà il ya
une erreur dans ta phrase à deux choses
d'abord sûr il ya 80% de mariages deux
divorces à paris donc arretez de croire
que je crois pas qu'il faille faire un
peu de tout à fait paris d'un sur deux
ça prouve bien qu'on re contraire
l'amour c'est scientifique c'est
chimique quand on couche avec quelqu'un
on sait très bien que ça le fera ou pas
petit 1 et pour répondre à deux
questions qui est beaucoup plus
intéressante
moi je pense que quelqu'un qui est
artiste qui est curieux comme franck
dubosc
je pense que oui nous deux on pourrait
avoir un début d'aventuré que des
mauvaises nouvelles se soit pas me faire
punir non plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais ces lois ne pas vider un sentiment
c'est parce que ça aurait pu tomber
juste à côté
non non et non et non